Hey Republicans have actually done
something honest and sincere for a
change in the frequently asked questions
section of the website for the American
Health Care Act Republicans have
officially gotten rid of the part where
they promised that patients with
pre-existing conditions won't have to
pay more for health insurance they've
done this very quietly but it's been
noticed this is what the section about
pre-existing conditions used to look
like okay and as you can see it used to
say that they will prohibit health
insurers from denying coverage or
charging more money to patients based on
pre-existing conditions here's what they
got rid of and as you'll see they got
rid of the or charging more money part
where now their promises we will
prohibit health insurers from denying
coverage to patients based on
pre-existing conditions Republicans are
famous for being totally out of touch
with technology maybe they didn't
realize that when you delete something
from the internet it doesn't actually
make it go away but this is basically
what Trump does all the time saying
something that he's on record as having
said was never actually something that
he said so is the promise not important
now to prevent costs from exploding for
people with pre-existing conditions or
was the bill just to completely hastily
haphazardly put together mess from the
start Republicans are touting insurers
won't be allowed to deny coverage to
people with pre-existing conditions but
that's very different than it will be
affordable if you go to the AHCA website
now it says quote the MacArthur
Amendment - a HCA does allow states to
seek a limited waiver to allow the
insurance companies to charge higher
premiums for a person in the individual
health insurance market with a health
condition this will effectively make
insurance unaffordable for people with
pre-existing conditions in many
situations making the protections
basically useless it's such weaseling
Pat let's say we live in a country where
even access to safe drinking water
wasn't a foregone conclusion oh wait
actually well in the u.s. access to safe
drinking water is
necessarily a foregone conclusion but
okay let's imagine that it was more
widespread okay I say I will guarantee
that every person in the country has
access to clean drinking water
no one will be denied water and then you
look into the details and it turns out
well in some parts of the country if you
live really for example you can get
clean drinking water
it's $1,000 a gallon I'm not literally
denying access there's access but it's
at a completely unaffordable price
that's exactly what Republicans plan to
do here would the pre-existing
conditions thing I think the problem
here is a lot about messaging because
while everyone knows that Obamacare
makes it so that health insurance
companies can't deny people based on
pre-existing conditions yeah not
everyone knows that they're not allowed
to charge higher premiums correct and
this allows Republicans to say oh well
we kept the same provision from
Obamacare that things exactly the same
where it's completely not there are a
number of areas where Republicans are
playing the game of saying we are
keeping X from Obamacare however what is
not being said forthrightly is some
combination of number one they're
keeping it with no respect to how it can
be priced pre-existing conditions is one
example of that and number two they're
keeping it but allowing participants in
the health care market to get a waiver
to not have to abide by it
what the use of what use are rules that
one can waive out of having to follow
this goes back to the heart of their
argument when it comes to health care
because it's all about for them just
guaranteeing access yes and even if that
means you get put into a high-risk pool
where your premiums are through the roof
that's good enough for them you
technically have access you can't afford
it because of what it will cost you but
hey there is something there for you and
it's absolutely disgusting it's
disgusting that these political games
are being played with people's health
people are going to die because of this
and whatever congressman Labrador says
as we talked about earlier in the show
people do die because of lack of access
to care and it's absolutely horrifying
today's program is made possible in part
by Dollar Shave Club the smarter choice
you can get a great shave at a great
price delivered to your door I hate
having to schlep to the store to buy
cheap disposable razors that give me a
cheap shave or spending a fortune on
razors with gimmicky Shea
technology that I never needed to begin
with and when I use my Dollar Shave Club
executive razor with the dr. Carver's
shave butter the blade gently glides
giving me a very very smooth shave and
the dr. Carver's shave butter is
transparent for a more precise shave no
opaque cream that make it so you can't
even see what you're doing it also helps
to prevent ingrown hairs and fights
razor bumps you can make the smarter
choice by short joining Dollar Shave
Club for a limited time new members get
their first month of the executive razor
with a tube of dr. Carver's shave butter
not really bladder it's a vegan approved
for only $5 with free shipping after
that razors are just a few bucks a month
that is a $15 value for five dollars in
your first month box you get the awesome
heavy handle a full cassette of four
cartridges and a tube of the shave
butter after your first month you'll get
replacement cartridges that ship
automatically at their regular price no
hidden fees no commitments cancel
anytime you can only get this offer at
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash Pakman
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash PA que
ma n